It’s got to be pretty hard to top a villain
quite so devious and terrifying as Thanos,
but that doesn’t mean it can’t be done.
From death gods to demons to dictators and
beyond, here are the Marvel villains who could
give the Mad Titan a run for his money.
Sure, Thanos killed half the universe, but
he did it in the pursuit of what he saw as
a higher purpose.
Hela doesn't need a reason to kill: death
is who she is and what she does.
“I am Hela, Odin's first-born, commander
of the Legions of Asgard, the rightful heir
to the throne, and the goddess of death.”
When she kills you, you go to her realm of
Hel, which is 'Hel with one L' if you're keeping
track, and become part of her undead army,
which, as afterlives go, doesn't sound particularly
fun.
This is why Vikings try so hard to prove their
value as warriors, because only the bravest
and best are chosen by the Valkyrie to spend
eternity feasting in Odin's great hall of
Valhalla.
In theory, everyone else goes to Hel.
The Marvel version of Hela was introduced
by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby in Journey into
Mystery #102.
Her intricate armor and multi-horned helmet
are classic Kirby designs, and help make Hela
one of his scariest-looking characters.
In fact, of all Thor's enemies, she's probably
the scariest.
After all, it's not easy to stop someone from
killing whoever they want when they have dominion
over the realm of death.
Kang the Conqueror is a strategist by nature.
He never makes a move until everything is
arranged perfectly, and he's confident that
whatever happens is certain to go his way.
Because he’s from the far future, Kang has
access to time travel, meaning that when he's
orchestrating his manipulative plans, he can
change the past to make the future he wants
more likely.
Anytime the Avengers face Kang, they have
to realize that he may have already changed
their timeline in ways they aren't even aware
of.
“I hope you enjoy the rest of your days
on this dead Earth, for this is where I leave
you.”
As you might expect, conflicts with Kang can
get pretty confusing.
He first appeared in 1964's Avengers #8, but
a previous time-traveling villain named Rama-Tut,
who'd appeared a year before in Fantastic
Four #19, was later revealed to be Kang from
another place in his timeline.
Thanks to the convoluted nature of time travel,
you never know when more than one Kang might
show up, and at times he may even be at war
with different versions of himself, as happens
in the "Kang War" storyline that started in
Avengers #128.
Mess with Kang and you’ll soon wish you’d
never been born.
Marvel is lousy with demons, but none greater
than Mephisto.
Inspired by Mephistopheles from the legend
of Faust, Mephisto has been Marvel's official
Satan stand-in for over 50 years, ever since
his debut in The Silver Surfer #3 by Stan
Lee and John Buscema.
He's the devil who holds Doctor Doom's witch
mother captive in his own version of Hell.
He's also the one who made the deal that turned
Johnny Blaze into Ghost Rider.
Like the demon on which he was based, Mephisto
will show up and say plenty of nice things
to you if he thinks you might sign on his
dotted line, but if you don't do exactly what
he wants, you’ll soon find out that he's
more than capable of ruining your life...
and your afterlife.
The Hate-Monger was a mysterious villain who
first appeared in Fantastic Four #21 in 1963.
He's an unnerving masked figure in a peaked
hood that immediately brings to mind the Ku
Klux Klan, only he’s also got a ray gun
that makes people hate each other.
He eventually turns out to be none other than
Adolf Hitler, or maybe just one of his doubles
or clones, who assumed his new identity after
fleeing Germany.
This Hitler dies at the end of that first
Hate-Monger story, but it soon turns out that
hate itself isn’t so easy to kill.
What makes the Hate-Monger scary isn’t just
that he's Adolf Hitler.
The scary thing about the Hate-Monger is the
idea of Hitler and the hate he represented
being practically impossible to kill.
“There are no men like me.”
“There are always men like you.”
He just keeps coming back, over and over,
with new and more powerful technology every
time.
Introduced in issue #5 of The Ultimates 2,
the First Firmament is the living embodiment
of the first universe that ever existed, back
at the dawn of time.
Attacked by the very beings it had created,
its consciousness survived and remained in
the void.
When Eternity, the eighth living universe
to exist, was weakened by other events out
in the cosmos, the First Firmament returned
and sought revenge.
The sheer scale of the cosmic power wielded
by the First Firmament, who has no regard
for life in our universe, is deeply terrifying
on a cosmic, existential level.
Fortunately, the Ultimates and Galactus were
able to help Eternity defeat the First Firmament,
but it was doubtless a close call with an
unusually powerful and entirely evil being.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
supervillains are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.